hey guys my name is Jess today is the
twelfth of October and you're tuned into
games bunnies DLC pack announcements
have been all the rage over the last
couple of weeks and now EA has come out
to announce several of them to star wars
battlefront the season pass will grant
you access to for expansion packs but EA
workg on exactly when we'll get our
hands on them or what will be in them
however they did say the pact will be
filled with new content that will take
you to new locations across the galaxy
far far away sony maps i guess the
season pass also allows people to get
access to each expansion two weeks early
and adopt a fancy shoot first amote
listings on the Xbox Playstation and
origin stores also just the season pass
will run you 50 bucks and if we're
expecting EA and dice to follow their
DLC model for Battlefield games the
individual packs will probably cost you
fifteen dollars should you want to
splash out on the season pass ahead of
time you can also grab the
newly-announced Ultimate Edition
Battlefront which is essentially the
deluxe edition plus the season pass the
Wall Street Journal has reported pretty
impressive sales figures for batman
arkham knight and mortal kombat x the
article compared the success of Warner
Brothers interactive entertainment in
comparison to the less impressive Warner
Brothers movie division and claim to
both games sold more than 5 million
units independently elsewhere in the
article it lists that Lego Jurassic
world has sold about 4 million copies
it's unclear whether they meant shipping
units to retailers or selling through to
customers batman arkham knight debuted
strongly despite being undermined with a
very buggy pc version Rocksteady have
assured gamers that the PC Edition will
be back on shelves by the end of October
finely dice has responded to criticism
over the frame rate and resolution of
Star Wars Battlefront in response to
criticisms that the Battlefront beta ran
at only 900 p on playstation 4 and 7 20
on xbox one technical director john
anderson has said that frame rate will
take
ority over resolution to deliver the
best gameplay experience he explained
frame rate and fidelity is indeed king
don't want to sacrifice it for
resolution but it's a choice each game
team does while a previous tech analysis
from digital foundry found the beta was
targeting 60 frames per second they
discovered the frame rate dropped to
during intense encounters on the Xbox
one no no down in that comment section
what you think of the Star Wars
Battlefront beta so far you can add
against but we've got stories on the
Dark Souls 3 beta and the halo 5 launch
trailer that is everything I have for
you today but do pop back same time
tomorrow for a bunch more news